[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pensez vous qu astérix était courageux
à votre avis était-il plus courageux
qu'un sportif qui tous les jours
s'entraîne pour dépasser ses limites
était-il plus courageux qu'un
entrepreneur qui porte son entreprise et
porte ses salariés
était-il plus courageux que celui qui
organisant un grand événement
décide de réaliser son rêve
et été plus courageux que le chercheur
qui choisit de ne pas suivre le
consensus est proposé un autre paradigme
des exemples comme celui ci comme ceux
ci il y en a plein
elia les vôtres
car on a tous un jour eu à soulever
comme astérix un menhir alors bien sûr
il n'avait pas la forme du menhir mais
il en avait probablement le poids un
poids psychologique est peut-être le
poids de la peur
alors pour astérix c'était facile
parce que lui il y avait la potion de
panoramix et pour nous
comment faisons nous
je suis docteur en psychologie
aujourd'hui mais j'ai commencé par la
diététique et puis ensuite par de la
psychologie fin de l'un des sciences du
langage en master en sciences du langage
pour aller vers la psychologie puis
ensuite la micronutrition aujourd'hui je
suis persuadé que les ressources dont
nous avons besoin pour le courage sont
multiples j'aime présenter les choses à
travers trois mots le beau le bien le
bon
également
à travers des neurotransmetteurs
que j'appelle la dose alors j'aimerais
vous les présenter assez rapidement ces
neurotransmetteurs
ils ont un mode de fonctionnement très
complexe et pas la prétention ici de les
présenter dans leur intégralité mais
j'aimerais simplement vous donner
quelques pistes d'interprétation pour
que vous puissiez vous aussi vous les
approprier ces neurotransmetteurs les
voici le premier c'est le premier de la
dose
c'est le d de la douze
la dopamine la dopamine c'est un plus
avec un point le plus avec un point
c'est du bonheur c'est du plaisir
immédiat point barre
c'est l'émotion positif qui surgit c'est
quelque chose qui va vous permettre de
pouvoir avoir du plaisir activer le
circuit de la récompense est en général
quand ce circuit de la récompense
s'active alors on recommence c'est ça la
dopamine ça nous donne les
endocrinologues enders dire ça nous
donne c'est ce plaisir immédiat qui
arrivent et la dopamine et bien elle est
certes sécrétée dans le cerveau mais il
faut savoir qu elle est aussi généré par
l'alimentation quand vous prenez de la
phénylalanine un acide aminé essentiel
alors il va se transformer en tyrosine
et si tout se passe bien et bien alors
on va voir de la dopamine
premier lire deuxième
neurotransmetteur c'est l'ocytocine
alors je vous ai expliqué la dopamine
c'est un plus avec un point du bonheur
immédiat et d'ailleurs la dopamine bien
souvent en psychologie positive on parle
de bonheur et de nickel je vous renvoie
d'ailleurs vers les travaux de martin
seligman si vous voulez creuser un petit
peu la chose l'ocytocine c'est du
bonheur points reliés à du bonheur
points c'est le neurotransmetteur de
l'attachement c'est celui qui va
permettre de pouvoir permettent de voir
le plaisir d'un côté reliés au plaisir
de l'autre ces deux neurotransmetteurs
de l'attachement alors comme la dopamine
il est issu de l'évolution de l'espèce
hélène et il est même issue de ce lien
que la maman créé avec son enfant car on
est une espèce qui ne peut pas vivre
seul le bébé quand il naît il a besoin
de sa maman et bien l'ocytocine est
générée au moment de l'accouchement et
elle est aussi généré probablement pour
permettre ce lien d'attachement qui va
permettre à l'enfant de pouvoir grandir
en sécurité alors les mamans ont certes
ce privilège mais les papas ou aussi et
les hommes et tout le monde a aussi la
possibilité de pouvoir générer 7
ocytocine par le simple fait de prendre
soin de l'autre
prendre soin à chaque fois que l'on
prend soin on génère ce plus pour soi on
génère le plus pour l'autre et on relie
les deux c'est ça le site hocine
troisième neurotransmetteur la
sérotonine je viens de présenter avec un
plus trois petits points autant la
dopamine cdu plus point bas on s'arrête
hop c'est du plaisir immédiat du plaisir
qui fait du bien la sérotonine c'est du
plaisir qui dure
la sérotonine c'est le neurotransmetteur
de la satisfaction il est attaché à nos
valeurs il est attaché au sens que l'on
donne à la vie il est attaché à tout ce
qui peut nous permettre de nous donner
de la satisfaction durable
certes o'neal et ses trois petits points
quand on les inverse on va obtenir les
endorphines c'est le e delà de la dose
ces trois petits points c'est bien
souvent les forts qui nous amène ensuite
à terme à la récompense et les
endorphines ce sont des morphine
endogène qui nous permette de pouvoir
supporter cet effort est allé jusqu'à
cette récompense ça nous permet
d'endormir la douleur pendant cet effort
là
alors là la dose quand tout va bien
finalement elle pourrait avoir ce schéma
là sains plus propres 1
un plus qui est relié un autre plus
trois petits points et puis un autre
plus ouais là c'est quand tout va bien
mais le courage on sait bien que c'est
pas quand tout va bien
qu'il se manifeste
le courage bien souvent il se manifeste
en situation de stress
alors le stress c'est en scellier qui
est à l'origine de ce
concept qui a permis de pouvoir
expliquer le stress un chercheur dont on
ne parle à mon avis pas assez il est à
l'origine du concept général
d'adaptation et il a présenté le stress
et ensuite on l'a compris à travers
trois phases que j'aimerais pouvoir vous
présenter
alors je pourrais prendre un exemple
mais j'aimerais que vous preniez le
vôtre
essayez de sélectionner dans votre vie
une situation alors ya le stress positif
certes c'est pas forcément celui non
durant lequel on a le plus besoin de
courage
il ya aussi le stress négatif et c'est
bien souvent lac se manifeste le courage
alors prenez un épisode de votre vie
peut être pas forcément un épisode le
plus heureux mais vous allez voir qu'il
y aura une fin positive
allons-y
découvrons ce syndrome général
d'adaptation le voici on peut le
présenter avec une courbe des courbes
comme ça dans ses courbes là vous avez
la première phase la phase de stress
stress négatif qu'est-ce qui se passe
l'adrénaline la dre de lille arrive
c'est la copine de la dopamine
d'ailleurs donc à ce qu'elle fait elle
loue diop elle nous met en mouvement
elle nous permet de pouvoir surmonter ce
stress pour pouvoir réagir bien souvent
soit par la fuite soit par le combat en
tout cas elle donne de l'énergie à notre
corps pour pouvoir y arriver et vous
voyez d'ailleurs que le magnésium là
aussi va soutenir la fonction musculaire
pour nous permettre de pouvoir y arriver
ça c'est quand le stress est ponctuelle
on y répond et on y répond naturellement
ça ce que l'on a en nous cette
adrénaline et ce magnésium bien d'autres
processus mais au moins ceci si le
stress continu si le stress perdure
alors on va entrer dans une autre phase
qu'on appelle la phase de résistance
dans cet autre phase on retrouve un
neurotransmetteur de la dose et même
deux on retrouve là vous à la voyez
envers la sérotonine 7 sérotonine c'est
quand le stress perdure alors on se dit
allez je tiens j'ai des valeurs ses
valeurs c'est ce à quoi je tiens c'est
ce qui me permet de pouvoir continue on
s'assoit sur ses 20 ans on s'appuie sur
ses valeurs et on y va et on y va dans
la joie parce que la sérotonine nous
procure de la joie de la joie profonde
axé sur nos valeurs
et puis au fur et à mesure
vous voyez que le magnésium lui
commence à être en déficit on commence à
s'épuiser un petit peu est arrivé un
certain moment quand le magnésium est
vraiment très bas qu'est ce qui se passe
bas la sérotonine elle aussi s'épuise
alors ce qui nous permettait de pouvoir
garder une bonne humeur ma petit à petit
s'arrête la sérotonine chute et vous
voyez quand même temps une autre amie de
la sérotonine la mélatonine elle fut
aussi la mairie la mélatonine c'est
l'hormone de l'endormissement c'est ce
qui nous a des bien dormir vous
comprenez que la conséquence de la chute
de mélatonine c'est les troubles du
sommeil alors qu'est-ce qui se passe on
commence à puiser dans nos ressources
et regardez vous comment vous étiez à ce
moment là qu'est ce qui se passait
et quand on continue un peu de stress
comme ça et qu'on ne renie charge pas
ses ressources bas qu'est ce qui se
passe la sérotonine a chuté le magnésium
est en déficit la mélatonine est aussi
en déficit qu'est ce qui reste eh bien
il reste l'hormone qui a servi à prendre
le relais à l'adrénaline c'est le
cortisol le cortisol sel ne retransmet
fins elle c'est l'hormone qui nous
permet de pouvoir maintenir le stress
est tenu tenir tenir pendant cette phase
de résistance et quand on arrive en
phase d'épuisement et bien ya plus que
le cortisol qui tiens qu'est ce qu'on
fait on tient sur les nerfs
il n'y a plus rien y a plus que quoi
mais il ya bien souvent plus que les
autres les autres qui sont là pour nous
soutenir les autres qui sont là pour
nous dire allez tiens et puis peut-être
un thérapeute dont vous aurez besoin si
effectivement vous arrivez dans cette
phase là parce que quand le canton tient
sur les nerfs et qu'il n'ya plus que le
corps qui tient et plus la tête et bien
si le cortisol lâche alors c'est la sas
l'as l'effondrement et c'est votre
physique qui lâche
alors ce que je veux dire à travers
cette courbe bah c'est que oui le
courage c'est psychologique oui le
stress la résistance aux tresses certes
c'est psychologique mais c'est pas que
psychologique et quand on regarde cette
dose et oui il ya de la dopamine oui il
ya de la sérotonine willi haag
l'ocytocine est à chaque fois que vous
avez été en phase de stress vous aviez
besoin de quelque chose dans la phase
d'alarmé c'est probablement la dopamine
qui vous a aidé c'est le beau c'est ce
qui vous a donné la motivation de
pouvoir aller de pouvoir avancer de
pouvoir mener à terme cette chose qui
peut être
vous à stresser mais il y avait quand
même quelque chose qui vous motive et
derrière
dans la phase de résistance c'est
probablement la sérotonine et c'est
probablement les valeurs vous êtes allé
chercher à l'intérieur de vous même ses
valeurs profondes qui vous ont permis de
tenir dans la durée et dans la phase
peut-être d'épuisement et j'espère bien
avant et bien il y avait de l'ocytocine
il y avait toutes les personnes avec
lesquelles vous avez noué des liens ces
liens d'attachement qui font qu'elles
sont là et qu'elles sont là y compris
dans la difficulté on dit souvent pour
connaître nos amis dans la difficulté
bah oui on reconnaît les personnes avec
qui on a créé un lien d'attachement
suffisant pour qu'elle soit encore là
pendant cette période là
alors
finalement si on devait se dire qu'il y
a peut être une formule pour cette
potion magique de panoramix
je dirais que cette potion elle est en
nous et que le courage s'appuie sur le r
et se r ce sont nos ressources elles
sont certes différentes pour chacun pour
chacune quel est votre beau quel est
votre bien ce qui vous a line quelles
sont vos valeurs quel est votre manière
de vous relever de vous relier aux gens
qu est ce qui vous donne qu'est-ce
qu'elles sont vos valeurs fondamentales
qu'est ce qui vous fait vous tenir droit
tous les jours et avancer quelles sont
les personnes à qui vous tenez tout cela
constitue vos ressources et c'est ça qui
vous donne du courage merci
[Applaudissements]